do you split your time on the regular  between facebook instagram  uh oculus whatsapp or is it sort of  every day has a little bit of everything  yeah  i definitely split my time a bit more  because there are just so many pieces at  this point that if i were trying to tune  into everything every day then it would  just be too much context switching so  as a matter of fact what i try to do is  like have a theme for a week and you  know maybe usually i can't get away with  just one theme but  and i'll try to do two or three things  in a week and have most of my time be  focused on on kind of nailing that and  doing a good job at that then of course  different things come up i'm talking to  people throughout the day but you know  we have really good people running each  of the apps you know it works well as a  team and that allows me to focus on on  you know some of the stuff that i think  is the most important and and whatever  is coming out that that um that i need  to deal with